fès et le secteur boisé qui est menacé
par le projet d'écoquartier alex
beauvais n'était pas un militant avant
d'apprendre qu environ 60 hectares de la
forêt à côté de chez lui allait se faire
raser c'est un non-sens de procéder
encore de cette façon là puis je
trouvais que c'était une insulte à
l'intelligence d'appeler son écoquartier
donc je décide de me pose maintenant
militants avec son groupe sos pour la
forêt du lac jérôme il saisit l'occasion
d'en faire un enjeu électoral
toutes les candidates saint girons ont
pris position mission accomplie j'en
suis très heureux non me les avait
forcés finalement parler d'environnement
j'aurais tort jobs pour ce faire il a
organisé un débat électoral sur l'unique
thème de l'environnement avec l'aide de
vire au vert cette coalition
environnementale a aidé à l'organisation
de plus d'une quarantaine de débat au
québec une première pour des élections
municipales
preuve que l'environnement devient
incontournable la vague écologiste au
mini si pâle a vu le jour au printemps
moi je pense qu'on peut dire que ce
succès parce que ça fait des semaines
que son temps et son spa l'environnement
avec sony sport environnement la vague
est un réseau bénévoles pour soutenir
les candidats écologistes peu importe
l'allégeance peu importe la municipalité
je pense que la vague écologiste a été
une révélation pour moi ça a été le
parfait
tremplin pour me permettre de me sentir
seuls et
1980 vu deux personnes officiellement
qu'ils ont franchi le pas du pouvoir
comme ça sur la vague les municipalités
ayant juridiction sur l'aménagement du
territoire elles deviennent des actrices
incontournables de la lutte aux
changements climatiques
les aires protégées
c'est quelque chose qui va rester les
rivières la protection des rivières ou
aussi alors toute la question
environnementale
toute la question des gaz à effet de
serre la décarbonisation la transition
énergétique
les municipalités dans leurs rôles lange
le cmem cristallisé autour de plusieurs
terrains de golf comme à rosemère
chambly ou saint jean sur richelieu la
vision des années 70 du béton de
l'asphalté puis la construction pour
avoir de l'impôt foncier c'est assez
alex beauvais rêve qu au jour du vote la
nature reprenne ses droits